[Music]
I'd like to welcome everybody to
tonight's class on chest tactics
we've been going through all my examples
are taken from the book the game of
chess by tarish it was written in 1935
tarish was a world champion contender
he didn't win the match he played
Emanuel Lasker he lost but he was a
great player he's a German he was an
amateur he was a MD by a profession he
had a medical practice
anyway he brote a great book and I take
my examples from his book were almost
finished with all the middlegame
examples so tonight will be the last set
of examples from his book this is the
first one we're going to go over
tonight's topic what we have a few
topics only a few examples each topic
the first topic is this position and it
is that you can advance pawns
so by advancing pawns against the enemy
king or queen position you in this case
it's not a win but black can save the
game by advancing his pawns in
counter-attack against white so before
we go into the moves let's look at the
position a little bit you'll notice
right off the bat that white as a bishop
stuck down blacks throat on the d6
square it's supported by a pawn on e5
and that's supported by a pawn on f4
White's Queen isn't in an aggressive
position it is blocked by the pawn on c6
though and White's rooks ones on D to
protecting the bishop the other ones on
f1 it can move over to that open file by
rook to d1 counting the pawns each side
has two four six seven pawns
pons forces are even two rooks Bishop
and a queen notice that the bishops are
different colors the black bishops on a
white square and the white bishops on a
black square does anyone in the audience
know what that's referred to in chess
it's called bishops of opposite colors
now the interesting thing about bishops
of opposite colors is they often lead to
a drawn game and the reason they do the
white bishop can only move on black
squares and conversely the black bishop
can only move on white so white can
basically attack black squares using his
bishop and he can be supported by the
rooks and queen the bishop can be
conversely black can only attack white
squares because both sides are attacking
different squares the attacks and
defenses tend to balance out if both
bishops were in the same color square
you might trade them off and then it
wouldn't be it wouldn't be so many drawn
games okay so the so right off the bat
you see white has more space and chess
space is the number of squares you can
move your pieces to and we say control
when you can move your pieces two
squares and the opponent can't oppose
them so see the bishop the white bishop
on d6 there's no piece that can take it
it's protected by a pawn so it can't
take it without losing a rook for a
bishop and a rooks worth five pawns or
five points and a bishop is worth three
pawns or three points
so a rook taking that bishop even if
they get the pawn that the bishop and
pawn would be for and the rook would be
five that would still be advantageous to
white so basically that Bishop on d6 is
immune to capture it's very strong the
fact that it's on the
six-row see how it breaks blacks
position onto the Queen side and King
side black it's a hard time defending
blacks Queen is pretty well placed
notice that the black bishop on the
white squares blocked by a pawn on c6
and a pawn on f5 and see how most of
blacks pawns are white squares when you
play chess in endings it's bad for your
bishop in this case black's bishop on a
white square to have your pawns on the
same color square they get in the way of
moving your bishop around the board they
block it now White's has C in whites
Casey is four pawns on black squares but
the big difference between white and
black is White's Bishop is in front of
his pawns and black is B Bishop is
behind the pawns so the bottom line is
even though the material is even white
has a big positional advantage black is
defending black would be very happy to
get a draw out of this game now the
question is it's blacks move how can
black get a counter-attack going and
save the game now the topic is advanced
pawns well let's look at the black pawns
what's the most advanced pawn for black
would anyone care to hazard which pawn
is most in advanced age four you're
right so that's the pawn that we're
thinking about so given that as
background what do you think is blacks
best move in this position
yes h3 now let's let's look what that
does the h3 black pawn attacks that pawn
on g2 notice that when the pond was on
h4 it was was on a black score now it's
on a white square it's attacking the
pawn on g2 now if white moves the pawn
on g2 let's say pawn takes pawn black
can't take it back right away but it
opens up that diagonal for the white
queen and the king and if the bishop on
d7 can move to if that pawn on c6 can
move up one Square and the bishop can go
Bishop to c6 it'll pin the White Queen
against the king this is the basis of
Black's counter-attack
that's why h3 is such a good move it
messes up blacks King side pawn position
well let's see what white does white
didn't take the pawn see white didn't
want the pawn there where it could be
attacked by the black rook and then the
rook both works might line up on the
rook file or it could take the pod and
then the RIC would be attacking the pawn
in front of the King black would
probably win the game so white played a
defensive move keeping his pawns intact
and leaving the black work blocked by
his own pawn that's now on h3 okay now
black moved his Bishop to e6 where it
attacks that white pawn on c4 the white
pawn can't move up one square because
the bishop could go to d5 and pin the
Queen and white would have to give up
the rook rook takes Bishop to save his
queen anyway white chose to move his
Queen to see three words
to the pawn so that's a pretty simple
maneuver now blacks going to double
rooks see when black moved his Bishop to
e6 that was freed up the square that the
Rick just moved to then the other work
he'd come over
possibly anyway that black rook on d7
it's it's a very strong defensive
position so let's go on white doubled
rooks on the D file reinforcing his
advance bishop
now black advance the pawn to c5 he
opens up the white diagonal toward the
white King and he might be able to play
Queen to c6 check then the Queen working
down to G - that would be checkmate
protected by that advanced pawn white
would always have to keep a rook or some
piece watching this square so it ties
White's pieces down and keeps white from
winning the game actually white moves
the King over so that there's no check
on that diagonal black doubles rooks
white moves Queen to a3 what is White's
threat now say white had an extra move
what would his next move be anyone in
the audience care to hazard a guess
you could do that he can't do it right
away though because it would be Queen
takes who f Queen takes Czech Queen
takes Queen Bishop takes Queen it would
open up the two works against the work
down here on d2 and black would win a
rook yeah but he's white is trying to
threaten to take that pawn in the future
but he can't take it right away black
moves his pawn up when the pawn was on a
7 the Queen was attacking the pawn black
wants to be able to move his Queen away
from protecting the pawn so by moving
the pawn up where one squirts protected
by the pawn on b7 that will allow black
to move his Queen away in the future
remember black wants to move the Queen
here but he doesn't want to lose the
pawn by Queen takes pawn so he moves it
here first okay let's see what white
does Oh white took the pawn okay
so black can't win the rook because his
Queens attacked by the bishop so if
black does rook takes rook the answer is
not Bishop takes Queen its rook takes
rook then he's threatening the Queen
so that's where the Queen wanted to move
anyway he wanted to go to c6 so now he's
pointing toward the king and if that
work were to move away from d2 the move
would be Queen to g2 would be a
checkmate see how the advanced pawn
gives the Queen a square to checkmate
the White King that's the advantage of
having an advanced pawn against your
opponent's king position white has to
keep a rook on d2 no matter what or one
of his other pieces okay white moves his
Bishop up he won the pawn now he moves
his bishop back where it was he doesn't
want to trade off the rooks he hopes to
attack with the rooks in the future and
see how the two black rooks are blocked
with no place to move by the bishop
black moved his pawn up from f7 to f6 he
wants to trade some pawns and try to
break up the pawn chain that's blocking
all blacks moves and by moving the pawn
here it lets the rook go over to the H
file as a possibility in the future
Black's threatening pawn takes pawn and
white actually now offers his rook he's
offering to lose the rook so Bishop
takes rook but there that might not be
so good for black because the pawn would
take and then the pawn would threaten
pawn takes Queen and notice that the C
files open and the rook could move to c1
in the future couldn't do it right away
cuz the Queen's there but when the RIC
went to see one it would attack the king
and queen on the same file but before
white can play work to c1 I'd have to
move this pawn here so the Queen would
protect the room
so Black Friday I going to take why you
did take it okay I was thinking and
white took back with the bishop I was
thinking taking back with the rook so
let's take a look at this and see why he
didn't take with the pawn okay let's see
what black does
okay now black is feeling anyway it's
blacks move who sees the threat for what
would White's next move be if it black
has to defend what would whites winning
move be if he could move two moves in a
row anyone in the audience care to
hazard well let's look at whites white
as a threat I'm what would White's move
be if white could move again well what
is his threat in this position pinning
the Queen to the king black has to stop
that threat and he felt compelled to
give back the exchange by rook takes now
white could try rook to c5 but it
doesn't work out too well for him let me
call my notes up here
oh yeah yeah so I actually don't have a
note on it but work to c5 we're gonna
call up the chess computer engine and
it'll help us analyze what happens F
work to c5 yeah work to D one check
that's the move rook here King to f2
then the other worked it down and then
King to e3 and we do the check we get
the Queen and it's with check and then
black picks the rook up on c5 so Rick to
c5 doesn't work out it looked like a
good threat but it doesn't actually work
out so black was perfectly safe when he
gave back the bishop because rook to c5
doesn't work because of the rooks down
and then the check on the King Queen so
white has to take with the pawn notice
the pawns protected sufficiently with
the rook and the Queen and black can't
take the c4 pawn because we would have
work to c5 check and now we do threaten
threat to c5 so in this case black just
moves his king out of the way
white police Queen to d3 which I have a
note is not the best move because it
allows rook takes pawn yeah it lost a
pawn so the reason Queen did Queen to d3
is a mistake it looks like yet the Queen
and rook protect the pawn but white
forgot that if the rook on d5 moves
there's a checkmate on g2 so Queen to d3
is a mistake because it loses the pawn
to rook takes pawn white can still hold
on though but now it's going to be a
draw he retreats here so the Queen
guards the checkmate square and white
threatens earth takes rook black
liquidates the rook pawn takes the rook
the Queen goes to c5 with Czech
notice that the Queen did not block the
pawn that would be a mistake so there's
two four six black pawns two four six
white pawns material-wise it ought to be
a draw that white pawn has two that
passed pawn has to be neutralized by
black so black Siddhant put his queen
here with Czech then he has time to
bring his King up and the King and Queen
block the pawn from advancing and the
King can move to d6 and then the Queen
and King can win that pawn white doesn't
have time to move his King up to defend
the pawn white might be feeling a little
trouble here but he has a resource so
King the c7 b3 King to d6 so now we uh
black is threatening to win the pawn and
he would be a pawn up there might be
winning chances cuz he he might win the
King and pawn ending white would have to
trade Queens because of that threat down
to g2 plus the black Queen could go to H
one check King moves in the Queen takes
rook pawn check so white counter-attack
see he gives up on the d5 pawn but he
sees he can take the f6 pawn with check
on the king
so naturally Queen takes pawn doesn't
work for black considers that Queen
takes pawn check so he takes with the
king the Queen takes the pawn now this
looks like it could be a draw because we
have five pawns on each side it's simply
a case that white can maybe get a
perpetual check see how the King isn't
the black Kings in the middle of the
board White's can probably get perpetual
check and get a draw that way or white
might be able to trade Queens and the
King could hold the ending we'll see how
it goes this is the blacks attempt to
win he's going to try to bring his King
in and king and queen are gonna attack
White's pawns and the white king so
here's a check King to d4 Queen to d7
check King to e3
so the king is right here and he blocks
these squares and the threat is Queen
here checkmate so he can't take the pawn
this would be checkmate he has to keep
checking the King and that works for
white so he plays Queen to e6 King to d4
Queen King the e3 Queen d6 King to d2
he's going to try to come over here and
win these pawns check
okay now this king is not here so
there's no checkmate threats against the
king so he can afford to take the pawn
way over here and he's threatening once
he wins this pawn
there'll be no checkmate down here and
he has a safe draw that's so he's hoping
to win this pawn and secure the draw
just a few more moves King comes down
the King is going to wipe these pawns
out and blacks hoping he can shove this
pawn and get a queen before white can do
damage on the other side of the board so
white takes the dangerous pawn black
takes that pawn now white
counter-attacks son this pawn and this
pawn at the same time naturally if King
takes pawn he's going to take that pawn
with check and then he can win this pot
and white plays a black plays Queen to
c6 black plays Queen to c6 saving both
pawns and then he can do King takes pawn
the only way white can protect this
button how can white protect this pot in
the audience Queen f7 but what is the
Queen protecting in his own position
from h7 the h2 pawn
so if Queen f7 this pawn is unprotected
and the Queen can drop down here forcing
the King here and then it's going take
spawn check and this pawn Falls and it's
all over
so actually white resigned here now
white could have played better and
gotten a draw let's see
remember I told you here we were here
and white made a bad move and lost that
pawn because of Queen down there
checkmate here's what White's let's see
what white should have played okay let's
see
okay so the computer says this is I
don't know if you're familiar with how
these work but this is the name of the
computer for its and eleven is the
version for its eleven and they do an
evaluation based on 1.000 is one pawns
worth so generally speaking a
grandmaster can win with one pawn so the
numeric evaluation see how its 0.00
daddy even equals means the computer
says it should be a draw with best play
by both sides okay so he says white
should play Queen to b4 and we won't go
into this in any detail but I just make
the one move look at changed a big plus
for white point seven nine I wonder why
that's the case
okay I didn't give it enough time it
changed its evaluation so it says white
has an advantage it's more than half a
pawn it's a pawn and it's like 3/4 of a
pawn almost 0.75 that's almost enough to
win and the plus / - means it's a big
advantage the right move for white is
Queen to b4 and white might have winning
chances but again in this position in
this position white blunder between to
d3 that's what the question mark is it's
a mistake and it allowed black to win
the pond and white couldn't do what it
takes for it because there was Queen to
g2 checkmate and black actually went on
to win the game this is similar
to the last one let's look at this
position it's White's move white wants
to advance this pawn and attack with
these four pawns in the black King
position so white starts off with E for
now remember in the topic is the advance
pawn and how in this case you don't win
with it but you can save the day so what
should black do with his pawn on h4 h3
same as in our last example it breaks up
the white pawns around the King and
gives black counter-attacks where he can
infiltrate with this Queen and try to
get to the g2 square so again white
pushes the pawn up now black brings his
Knight to d6 and black is threatening
Knight takes pawn but it looks like
Knight to d6 as a blunder doesn't it
looks to me like white could would fork
the knight and queen with that pawn on
e4 so the question is that's what's
going to happen but what should black do
well we know black wants to get his
Queen to g2 so black is going to move
his Queen to the white square next and
come into e4 after the pawn takes the
knight and then the queen of Threatened
queen of g2 checkmate
does everybody see that possibility well
let me do the move e5 winning the knight
see but it opens up that white diagonal
you see that so now the Queen eat that
you don't move that the Queen has to
move but you move it to the white square
and you get the Queen targeting Queen
going to Square where he can go Queen to
g2 and threaten checkmate it saves the
day so white takes the knight but now
now we're in the position that I started
with by mistake
and the threat is Queen here and move as
you said is rook to F - the only move to
stop checkmate
notice that the Queen here would protect
it but the white the black queen guards
the score so you can't drop the Queen
back and there's no other pieces that
could guard the G - squirt so he has to
do workup and now there's perpetual
check the King can't move so the work
has to drop back well it's not perpetual
check but it's a it's like perpetual
check it's the threat of mate rook has
to go up check throughout a mate it's
similar to a perpetual check so you
should keep in mind in your own games
that advanced pawns can give you either
attacking chances or counter attacking
chances okay let's go to our next now
we're going to go to another topic this
one is called the point queen Knight six
as a target the subject is Queen Knight
six as a target and black is actually
going to win the game and black in this
is the English notation this is the
queen Knight file blacks Queen Knight
six is this square we're not ready to
attack this square there's nothing to
attack it so we got to play through some
moves to set this up and we'll go
through it pretty quickly so white plays
b3 that's going to be our target black
brings his rook up he's going to double
rooks maybe and maybe open up that night
file by pawn takes pawn white plays h3
to give his King in an escape hole King
to h2 black moves his King over to the
corner he doesn't want to be checked on
those white diagonals white retreated
his bishop
White's thinking about playing the pawn
on g2 to g4 to a attack the black pawn
on f5 the bishop reroutes itself from a
seven where the knight can take the
bishop he's thinking he's gonna bring
the guard the black diagonals he doesn't
want to lose his bishop white does play
the g4 move black defense with the Queen
Queen moves to f3 I have a note that
that's not the best move the best move
is moving the bishop back to g3 okay so
going back a little bit the bishop went
to h2 not that h2 is a good square for
the bishop he wanted to stop blocking
the pawn so he could attack with the
pawn here having moved the pawn here he
moves he should have moved the bishop
back behind the pawn to give the bishop
more squares to go to in the future he
didn't do that okay so right here he
should have left the Queen here where it
blocks this pawn and protects this pawn
and he should have moved the bishop here
anyway now black has a slight advantage
black plays rook to a7
white plays g5b four so black blocks
this pawn with this pawn and now black
is going to move here and here and when
the pollen gets here we have our attack
on our b6 or a queen Knight six square
or the B 3 square which is our topic how
you can attack this square so this is
not a king site attack black is going to
attack with his rooks and win a pawn
this pawn is going to come up here he's
going to take care here when this pawn
is here see how it's not defended by any
pawns then the rooks can come in and the
Queen can come in and maybe win the pawn
way down the road so black plays Bishop
2g 3 a 5 H 4 a 4 so there's our attack
white plays the rook over this way he
wants to move this pawn up and attack
with his pawns black trades pawns as I
said this pawn is weak it's not
protected by any other pawns and black
can come here or here and here and maybe
bring the Queen down here and here and
then the rook and Queen can attack the
pawn mate maybe try to win it that's
what black is going to try to do black
plays rook to a3 Bishop to F - the Queen
protects the pawn for the time being
now black brings his Queen over white
moves the rook up so now he's got
working Queen protecting the pawn but
load notice these are open for the black
working Queen black drops down check
King goes up to the escape hole
black swings is rickover white wants to
trade works to ease his defense black
doesn't want to trade rooks so he moves
there the bishop drops back now white
wants to trade the work on g22 that rook
the Queen comes down white trades the
work now the King goes up the Rick goes
to f7 see how the work is blocked by his
bishop he can't move the bishop up
because the knight guards all the
squares so he's going to move he wants
the work to come to the a file so he has
to go up one square then he can go over
white plays Queen to d3 g6 before the
rook moves he had to protect the pawn on
f5 with the pawn so he could move the
rook if the rook moves right away the
answer would be Queen takes pawn
threatening Queen takes Knight
so g6 rook to d2 he wants to chase the
Queen away Queen goes to a-1 attacking
the bishop on a1 rook has to go back
Queen retreats the Queen retreats all
the way here because when the rook comes
over he wants his Queen behind the work
he's going to jump into White's position
rook first that's why he put the Queen
all the way back on the first row white
plays it so now the rook comes to a7
Queen moos rookie in white makes a error
here rook the d3 but Queen to d3 would
have been a better defense anyway
after work to de he he gets into more
trouble
black swings has worked to be 2
attacking the pawn and making room for
the Queen to come here here
black retreats white retreats the bishop
now the queen comes in attacks the
bishop
okay now the Queen comes over this way
the Queen's got to come here and attack
the bishop and then the Queen and we are
gonna be on this pawn white tries to
chase the Queen away goes back here now
black sees he can maybe win the game
after he trades Queens because the Queen
is a strong defender white trades Queens
he moves his King in chase the rook the
rook goes to b2 and he's on this pawn
it's defended by this rook the question
is what piece can black move to attack
this pawn the rook is in the right spot
whatever the piece can black move to
attack that pawn with the audience care
to hazard a guess has to be the knight
this is a white pawn on the white square
that black square bishops are not going
to do the trick so he's going to move
the knight around like Knight here here
here here and here and then the knight
and Rick attack the pawn and the bishop
can't defend the pawn and the King can't
cross this line there's no defense and
white wins okay now we're going to go
over another example this time the topic
is Queen Bishop 6 as a target I'm only
one example here yeah this is the
starting position now white wins this so
the topic is Queen Bishop 6 again in
English notation this is the Queen
Bishop
Square and this is the white six row so
this is Queen Bishop six the target of
our attack is this pawn white is going
to attack this pawn and try to win on
the Queen side he's going to move the
pawn here to block the pawn then he's
going to advance this pawn here this
pawn here this pawn here attacking this
pond then he can do pawn takes pawn
takes and bring his rooks in something
like that so we'll go through this
pretty quickly there's a number of moves
before we get to the critical position
so he chases the Queen away the Queen
has to go back to her home square now we
have the b4 pawn coming up moves the
knight out of the way h3 that's why did
white play h3 who in the audience would
care to give us the reason for that
that's true and there's one other reason
he wants to give the bishop an escape
square he doesn't want the night to go
here and liquidate the bishop this
bishop is very strong see how it goes
all the way here and prevents the rook
or the Queen can't go here and the work
can't go here he wants to preserve this
bishop at all costs so the main purpose
of the move is to give the bishop a
retreat square in case black plays
Knight here the other things you
mentioned are true - in the ending he
can move his king up in case black
should somehow get to the back row and
it does block the knight from coming in
- g4 - black plays Bishop to d7 now
white sees commencing his pawn attack on
the Queen side black plays Queen to c8
white gets his pawn up there now you can
see he is in fact initiating a direct
attack on that pawn we've still got
about 15 moves to go black plays there
now you should all black should only
have played this move if this pawn was
here then he can take the bishop and if
the bishop moved here he could take the
bishop here there's no purpose to this
move the bishop retreats here and this
Bishop this Knight is on the side of the
board it's on a bad square so this is a
mistake
Bishop retreats black retreats this
Bishop now white is going to attack with
this pawn and he's going to shove it up
here so these two white pawns attack
here and here and he breaks down blacks
defenses black plays Bishop to c7 this
Bishop was really bugging black so he
moved the bishop back and here - trait
to liquidate then he can move his Queen
here in the rook there for defense
well White's going to lose the bishop
he doesn't wanna let Bishop takes Bishop
check so he just takes it Queen takes
now we're at the culmination of whites
Queen side attack he attacks this pawn
and he threatened something like pawn
takes pawn Queen takes pawn pawn takes
pawn and Bishop takes pawn this rook
comes here and it attacks the Queen and
the two works here in the Queen this is
an isolated pawn White's going to bring
the Queen up then he'll threaten work
downs and he should win the game black
played b6 he didn't want to allow pawn
takes pawn this doesn't work out that
well I've got a note that that's a
mistake
white takes advantage of it by taking @
c6 so see how the pawns black played
here now we liquidate the pawn and c6
it's going to have a bishop or a queen
there naturally takes with the bishop
now we take the b6 pawn Black has a
choice it can take with the queen of the
pond
what's the drawback in taking with the
pawn who in the audience would care to
say what the drawback is yet Knight to
b5 the other thing is yeah that's very
strong because the bishops pinned pawn
takes pawn this becomes a passed pawn
and can be shoved up and get a queen so
he has to do Queen takes pawn and your
idea of Knights tonight five is a very
strong move to so he has to take with
the Queen but the drawback to the Queen
is we can activate our rook that's not
doing anything behind the pawn we can
swing it over here and win a temple
attacking the Queen drive the Queen back
now the knight comes in
with temple attacking the bishop that's
unprotected so now we got our knight on
the key center square our rooks are on
here the Queen's here whites blacks days
are numbered he has to retreat the
bishop white chooses to take the bishop
because the bishop guards key squares on
the Queen side black takes back oh okay
let's look at this position just a
smidgen longer so white did Knight takes
he has two choices Knight or Queen takes
what's wrong with Queen takes Knight
yes Bishop to b5 attacking the Queen the
Queen moves in the rooks gone so he
can't do that but there's a big drawback
to taking with the knight what was the
knight protecting on f8 h7 so white wins
the key pawn where is it where is it
right here there bishop takes 8 that
this is enough to win the game now we're
a pawn up blacks King side is bad his
knight on is on the side on h5 white
dominates the Queen side so the King
moves over white prudently pulls to the
bishop back he doesn't want to mess
around with the g6 blocking the bishop
in black boozes Knight to b6 white
immediately at 8 attacks the knight this
is blacks defender it blocks this rook
and the rook wants to go here so he
immediately comes here the night once he
gets rid of that night he can threaten
rook down to the seventh rank
black has nothing better than Knight
takes Queen takes he tries to defend
be seven with the rook rook drops in
anyway if like does Rick take suruc pawn
takes Jerrica we have a passed pawn and
it attacks the rook the rook moves then
we get Queen takes rook pawn so he can't
do rook takes rook
he tries Rick to c8 now we double rooks
again where it takes rook doesn't work
for black because pawn takes rook so he
tries he just tries to double rooks but
now Queen takes if he does rook takes it
would probably be the same thing worth
to be seven would probably win and if
Rick takes rook pawn takes Rick we'd
have that past pawn and the White Queen
would be able to either take the pawn on
a 7 so if rook takes rook here rook
takes pawn takes if Queen here we would
have Queen here check and Queen takes
pawn attacking the knight so the only
move he can try as Queen takes c7 but
now we get our rook in we're attacking
the Queen and the pawn on a7 at the same
time he tries to counter-attack with a
check but we have our xscape hole which
you pointed out now he goes Queen to d2
he tries to attack the bishop but White
is done with defending he's got the rook
in the 7th rank is to do is bringing
Queen and attacked this way and the game
will be over in just a couple moves so
he he doesn't defend the bishop or move
it
threatening Queen takes rook rook to f8
to defend the pawn who sees the winning
move one more move for White Queen takes
pawn very good and because the bishop
guards the escape hole
rook takes Queen or a care check work
back or takes her a checkmate and it's
all over and he can't protect the
checkmate by work here kisses nights
hanging Queen takes Knight would be
checkmate and we're out of time so if
that's it thanks for coming tonight
[Music]
you
[Music]